cambiare tutto questa è l'idea di fondo
l'idea di base infatti alla fine di
questa chiacchierata il vostro cervello
non vi consentirà più di fare le cose
che eravate abituati in passato non vi
dirò cosa fare ma lo capirete dai punti
che toccherò e dai dati che vi fornirò
posso dirvi questo perché ho fatto delle
esperienze nel campo del
dell'inquinamento soprattutto
dell'inquinamento marino è successo nel
2012 che facendo un viaggio subacqueo
avevo come la telecamera per fare delle
riprese subacquee sono andati in un
isola dell'indonesia un'isola bellissima
sperduta in mezzo altre migliaia di
isole deserte e simili il mi è capitato
che passeggiando sul retro di
quest'isola ho visto parecchi rifiuti in
questa spiaggia e mi sono stupito della
cosa perché erano eravamo veramente in
un paradiso terrestre
da lì avevo che appunto come la
telecamera e ho filmato questa questa
spiaggia per far capire che c'era
veramente un problema grosso sono
tornato in italia con occhi diversi e ho
notato che anche nelle nostre coste si
trovavano moltissimi rifiuti spiaggiati
cosa cosa ho fatto e quindi di queste
riprese sia fatta all'estero sia fatte
qui in italia ho cercato di avvisare il
mondo mi sembrava di essere veramente
l'unico perché nel 2012 ancora non si
parlava dell'inquinamento marino di
queste isole enormi di plastica
galleggianti e quindi ho fatto dei mini
documentari per raccontare quello che
stava succedendo ai nostri mari
quindi anche in italia ho passato le
spiagge o passato ogni insenatura del
friuli del veneto facendo proprio un
documentario che raccontava tutto quello
che veniva spiaggiato el 80 per cento di
questo come davano le statistiche
era costituito da plastica e quindi per
anni mi sono dedicato a fare conferenze
a far vedere questi documentari per
sensibilizzare le persone quindi non
sono stato fermo a lamentarmi non solo
protestato diciamo segnalato la cosa
avevo fatto qualcosa di azione pratica
era qualcosa di diretto quindi anche
raccogliere nelle spiagge rifiuti e fare
conferenze per sensibilizzare in
contemporanea a questo nel 2013
mi sono unito a un gruppo protezionista
dell'ambiente una associazione
internazionale che essi scelta questa
associazione mi ha permesso di entrare a
far parte di un gruppo di volontari che
si dedicano proprio la difesa del mare
anche con diverse navi in giro per il
mondo
così ho potuto anche conoscere tutti i
dati di quanto il mare fosse in pericolo
di quanto la pesca fosse eccessiva e
quindi unire tante conoscenze che la
maggior parte delle persone non hanno
quindi ancora di più la voglia di
difendere il mare di proteggere il mare
anche con cissè è però avuto l'occasione
di fare conferenze nelle scuole anche
con migliaia di ragazzi per parlare di
questi problemi dell'inquinamento marino
da plastica in modo particolare e
successivamente approfondendo queste
cose quindi documentandomi leggendo
libri sull'argomento mi sono focalizzato
su degli aspetti particolari che sono lo
scioglimento dei ghiacci
o ancora di più un aspetto non ancora
conosciuto dalla maggior parte delle
persone che l'acidificazione degli
oceani
l'acidificazione degli oceani è proprio
dovuta alle attività umane che fanno in
modo che la co2 emessa in atmosfera
penetri piano piano aumentando la
concentrazione
nel gas che l'atmosfera che respiriamo
piano piano viene assorbita dagli oceani
dai mari aumentando la ride carbonica
assorbita nel mare si forma l'acido
carbonico questo provoca un aumento
dell'acidità addirittura nella nell'era
post nell'era moderna nel nell'era
attuale abbiamo un acidità degli oceani
che 150 volte quella presente nell'era
preindustriale
che impatto ha questo abbassamento del
ph che numericamente da andando verso il
ph più basso in realtà sia un aumento
dell'acidità degli oceani
questo cosa provoca provoca una
difficoltà di sopravvivenza e di fissare
il carbonato di calcio degli organismi
che sono dei polipi marini come possiamo
vedere nella nell'immagine in questa in
queste immagini in cui i polipi sono
degli organismi animali presenti nel
mare che producono queste strutture
sembrano degli alberi colorati che in
realtà appunto sono strutture di
carbonato di calcio i coralli e e anche
i coralli molli comunque sono sono
sostanze sono degli organismi prodotti
da questi piccoli animaletti che hanno
una bocca e dai tentacoli e si nutrono
del pianto quindi cosa succede che sia
gli organismi che producono conchiglie
sia i coralli vengono sciolti da un
cambiamento della di questa cd tac ea un
cambiamento veramente esponenziale
questo porterà alla distruzione della
biodiversità enorme presente nelle
barriere coralline già la bella grande
barriera corallina australiana viene
dagli scienziati dichiarata tecnicamente
morta quindi possiamo dire che proprio
l'attività umana che cambia la
composizione dell'atmosfera e cambia
anche la l'acidità è la composizione
della vita marina dell'acidità dei mari
quindi sono le attività umane ogni
nostra azione sommata
di persone che porta a una
trasformazione del nostro pianeta quindi
dal pensare a occuparsi del mare di
quanto fosse grave il problema marino
poi pian piano mi sono reso conto che il
problema è veramente di tutto di tutto
il globo di tutto il pianeta sia delle
terre emerse di tutti i continenti sia
dell'atmosfera è un problema che
accomuna tutta l'umanità e dovrà essere
risolto da tutti i popoli da tutte le
persone che pian piano devono cambiare
le loro abitudini
queste emissioni vengono prodotte
dall'uomo perché per esempio il 25 per
cento delle gas serra vengono prodotte
nelle città molte persone magari pensano
che l'impatto maggiore è dovuto alla
industria dei trasporti che in realtà
produce gas era solo per un 14 per cento
e a questo proposito mi piace citare un
altro grosso problema secondo me perché
sporca le città inquina le strade dove
camminiamo ed emette anche questo gas
serra che il problema legato al fumo di
sigaretta pensate che produce gas serra
nel mondo a livello globale per lo 0 2
per cento quindi anche il fumo di
sigaretta un impatto sulla nota sulla
nostra atmosfera ci sono diversi studi
che dimostrano questo vi faccio vedere
alcune immagini alcune diapositive che
dicono perché hanno studiato le
emissioni di sia diesel euro 4 che di un
tir e hanno dimostrato che il fumo di
una sigaretta e mette più particelle più
micro particelle più polveri sottili un
altro dato importante è che hanno fatto
le analisi dei pm10 presenti in una
stanza dove viene fumato una sigaretta
le missioni di questi pm10 corrispondono
a circa 200 mila e 100 grammi per metro
cubo
ma se si continua a fumare sigarette in
questa stanza si arriva a 2000 1.100
grammi per metro cubo e dovete sapere
che nelle strade se in una città si
superano i 50 1.100 grammi viene fermato
il traffico e il traffico
automobilistico
quindi un da un dato da non trascurare
quindi un'abitudine diciamo non positiva
per tanti altri aspetti ma anche per
l'effetto serra che andrebbe ridotta o
addirittura stoppata completamente ma il
maggiore danno diciamo cambiamento
sull'atmosfera viene dato dalla da
quello che è legato alla nostra
alimentazione alle nostre abitudini
alimentari
tant'è che nel nell'atmosfera
dall'intera l'industria alimentare che
comprende la deforestazione per
preparare coltivazioni oppure negli
allevamenti intensivi e tutta
l'industria di produzione e trasporto
degli alimenti incide ben per un 24 per
cento di tutte le emissioni di gas serra
quindi ancora una volta sono le nostre
attività
le nostre attività umane le nostre
azioni quotidiane che cambiano il nostro
pianeta tant'è che l'era che stiamo
vivendo in cui siamo già entrate viene
chiamata antropocene perché trasforma
letteralmente il nostro pianeta
naturalmente lo trasforma in senso
negativo e dobbiamo essere noi a
invertire la rotta per impedire questo
aumento di temperatura che può arrivare
secondo le previsioni ta2 anche a 3,8
gradi centigradi di aumento su quello
che possiamo fare noi mi piace citare
una frase di bill gates che vi leggo per
non incorrere in errori e dice quando
comprate un'automobile elettrica un
hamburger vegetale anche se costa più
dell'alternativa dimostrata che c'è una
domanda per questi beni
non tutti possono permettersi di pagare
questi prezzi supplementari ma se siete
fra quelli che possono farlo è un modo
produttivo per contribuire
questo vuol dire che se qualcuno ha la
possibilità di usare dei beni che sono
amici dell'ambiente che sono sostenibile
farà in modo che
momenti la domanda di questi beni è pian
piano il prezzo possa calare e quindi
possono essere sempre più facilmente
disponibili a una platea molto più ampia
di persone
nel mio caso posso dire che anche qui
non sono stato fermo ma mi sono
informato ho studiato quando è venuto il
momento di cambiare macchina io devo
dire che già dieci mesi che uso una
macchina 100 per 100 elettrica e devo
confessarvi che la soddisfazione di
girare per le strade non emettendo
sostanze cancerogene è veramente grande
e così torniamo comunque al punto di
partenza l'idea iniziale che è quella di
cambiare tutto dobbiamo fare un reset
delle nostre abitudini delle nostre
vecchie conoscenze di quello che c'è
stato anche insegnato dai genitori dalla
società negli anni passati perché
dobbiamo proprio considerare che non
tutto quello che ci hanno insegnato e
corretto e giusto ed è giusto
soprattutto per il nostro pianeta
dobbiamo essere capaci di vedere le cose
in maniera differente e pensare ad ogni
nostra azione
che impatto possa avere sull'ambiente
facendo così abbiamo veramente il potere
di cambiare il futuro del nostro pianeta